GOOD AFTERNOON I LIKE TO CALL TO
ORDER THE HEARING OF THE PRIVACY
AND CONSUMER PROTECTION
COMMITTEE.
OF BY JUNE NINETEEN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN LET ME BEGIN BY
WELCOMING OUR NEWEST MEMBER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JESSE.
ARE GABRIEL TO OUR COMMITTEE.
AND WE ALSO HOUSE --
NICOLE OUR O. SECRETARY SO WITH
THAT WE HAVE TODAY WE HAVE A
TOTAL OF EIGHT BILLS IN TWO OF
WHICH ARE ON PROPOSED CONSENT.
AND I NOTICED THAT SENATOR HILL
IS ALREADY HERE SO WITH THAT
WITHOUT FURTHER ADO LIKE ASKING
TO COME UP TO PRESENT HIS BILL.
AND HE HOUSE AS BE.
THIRTEEN FIFTY FIVE WELCOME A
SENATOR HILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS SB THIRTEEN FIFTY
FIVE MAKES IT ILLEGAL TO
KNOWINGLY AND INTENTIONALLY
OPERATE IN UNMANNED AIRCRAFT
SYSTEM ON OR ABOVE THE GROUNDS
OF THE STATE PRISON OR A JAIL.
THERE ARE SEVERAL RECENT
INCIDENTS OF DRONES BEING USED
TO DROP CONTRA RAN INTO PRISONS
AND JAILS FOR EXAMPLE.
IN OCTOBER OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN A
SMALL DRONE CRASHED INSIDE THE
PERIMETER OF ELMWOOD
CORRECTIONAL FACILITY IN SANTA
CLARA COUNTY.
INVESTIGATORS FOUND A PACKAGE OF
MATH ONBOARD AN INMATE AT A HIGH
SECURITY FEDERAL PRISON IN
VICTORVILLE CALIFORNIA.
RECRUITED SOMEONE TO USE A DRONE
TO SMUGGLE INTO CELL PHONES IN
MARCH OF TWENTY FIFTEEN THE
PHONES WERE NOT FOUND BY PRISON
OFFICIALS FOR FIVE MONTHS IN
FEBRUARY NEAR DELANO'S KERN
VALLEY STATE PRISON.
A DRONE DROPPED A BAG FILLED
WITH CELLPHONES SIM CARDS
HACKSAW BLADES A HUNDRED EIGHTY
GRAMS OF HEROIN.
IN SIXTY NINE GRAMS OF MYTH THE
FOLLOWING DAY STAFF FOUND THREE
MORE BAGS CONTAINING DRUGS
LIGHTERS AND ROLLING PAPERS
AMONG OTHER ITEMS.
WELL SMUGGLING CONTRABAND INTO
PRISON OR JAIL THROUGH ANY
METHOD IS ILLEGAL STATUTE
CURRENTLY BARS DRONES FROM
FLYING NEAR NO STATUTE CURRENTLY
BARS DRONES FROM FLYING NEAR
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES.
SB THIRTEEN FIFTY FIVE UPDATES
CURRENT LAW TO MAKE CLEAR THAT
USING DRONES TO SMUGGLE
CONTRABAND INTO CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES IS ALSO UNLAWFUL.
S. B. THIRTEEN FIFTY FIVE DOES
NOT PROHIBIT DRONE TECHNOLOGY
BUT INSTEAD CREATES A PENALTY.
TO DEFEAT TERROR ANY
UNAUTHORIZED PERSON FROM
OPERATING A DRONE NEAT DRONE
NEAR A PRISON OR JAIL FACILITY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
MEMBERS THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
PLEASE [inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE LET'S
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS MISTER
CALDERON GO.
CENTER HELD THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD I'VE DONE
LEGISLATION IN THIS AREA --
TO TRY.
TO PROHIBIT THINGS FROM BEING
FLOWN OVER FENCES HAVE THAT WE
ALL NO SHOULD BE FLOOR OVER
FENCES ALONG WITH NOT
INTERFERING WITH OTHER PUBLIC
SAFETY TYPE UP --
SITUATIONS --
GOVERNOR VETOED THAT BILL I HOPE
YOU HAVE A BETTER CHANCE --
WITH YOUR BILL BUT HAPPY SUPPORT
I'M OF THE BILL TAKE YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH ERA.
WHEN WE HAVE QUORUM THEN WE
COULD TAKE THAT UP BUT ALSO
OTHER ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
ARE?
SEEING NONE I WANT TO THANK YOU
ALSO SENATOR FOR BRINGING THE
BILL FORWARD I WE HAVE SO MANY
OF US HAVE SEEN HIS BILL IN FACT
I UNDERSTAND THAT THE GOVERNOR
VETOED SIMILAR.
A BILL OF YOURS FROM LAST YEAR
WE CHANGE THE PENALTY.
FOR POSITION TO HOLD EXACTLY
CHANGE SOLVE THAT PROBLEM
EXACTLY THANK YOU VERY.
OKAY HAD MISTER OBERNOLTE --
BAKER RESEARCHER CENTER I'M
SUPPORTIVE OF YOUR BILL A AND I
THINK YOU FOR BRINGING FORWARD I
HAVE ONE CONCERN I JUST WANT TO
SHARE WITH YOU.
AND I JUST READING FROM THE BILL
YOU'VE GOT A AN EXCEPTION
INHERITED SAYS THIS SECTION DOES
NOT APPLY TO ANY ENTITY FOR WHOM.
THE FAA HAS AUTHORIZED THE USE
OF THE UNMANNED AIRCRAFT SYSTEM
IN THE UNMANNED AIRCRAFT SYSTEMS
OPERATED IN ACCORDANCE WITH THE
TERMS AND CONDITIONS OF THE
AUTHORIZATION.
AND I'M SURE YOU'RE AWARE THAT
THE FAA NOW REQUIRES.
THE LICENSED IN THE DRONES
THEMSELVES TO BE REGISTERED SO
I'M CONCERNED THAT YOU COULD
INTERPRET THAT AS BEING FAA
AUTHORIZATION AND I WOULDN'T
WANT ANYONE TO TRY TO USE THAT
AS A WAY TO GET AROUND --
THE PRO THE PROHIBITIONS IN YOUR
BILL SO I JUST WANT TO BRING
THAT TO YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
IT ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND WE WILL
LOOK INTO THAT AND MAKE SURE
THAT THAT DOESN'T TO FALL INTO A
CRACK THERE'S I THINK IT'S VERY
GOOD OBSERVATION THANKS.
THANK YOU ARE WITHOUT THE WHICH
LIKE A CLOSE HOW EXPECT WE ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU
MISTAKE I THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE
[inaudible]
BUT AS
SO I THINK.
WAS JERRY WAS
[inaudible]
YEAH
OKAY
.
I NOTICED THAT SENATOR GALGIANI
IS HERE SO LIKE TO WELCOME HER.
SHE IS GOING TO PRESENT ON ITEM.
NUMBER EIGHT SP THIRTEEN NINETY
SIX WITH DATA SENATOR ANYTIME
YOU'RE READY YOU MAY PRESENT.
AND TO THE AVAILABILITY OF
TECHNOLOGY INCLUDING GOVERNMENT
WEBSITES IT'S CRITICAL THAT ON
MY WEBSITES AND TECHNOLOGY BE
ACCESSIBLE FOR PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES.
SO THAT THEY CAN ACCESS
INFORMATION SERVICES AND
BENEFITS THAT THEY'RE ALREADY
ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE.
S. B. THIRTEEN NINETY SIX TAKES
IMPORTANT STEP OF MOVING TOWARD
ENSURING EVERY STATE AGENCY AND
ENTITIES WEBSITE IS IN
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE AND
FEDERAL DISABILITY ACCESSIBILITY
LAWS.
THESE ACCESSIBILITY REQUIREMENTS
HAVE BEEN IN THE LAW FOR YEARS
BUT ENSURING THAT ALL STATE
AGENCIES WEBSITES ARE COMPLIANT
HAS BEEN LACKING.
IT IS ESSENTIAL THAT PERSONS
WITH DISABILITIES HAVE THE SAME
ACCESS TO INFORMATION AND
SERVICES AS PERSONS WITHOUT
DISABILITIES HIS PROPOSAL WOULD
ESTABLISH THAT ACCOUNTABILITY.
I HAVE WITH ME TO SPEAK ON THIS
BILL CURTIS CHILD WITH
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA.
AND JEFF TOM WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF THE BLIND.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FAIR EITHER.
THAT YOU VERY MUCH EFFORTS
WITNESS PLEASE --
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA --
WE'RE VERY PLEASED TO SPONSOR
THIS LEGISLATION THAT WE THINK
IS CRITICAL. TO ENSURING THAT
WE'RE GETTING CLOSER TO HAVING
ALL OF OUR STATE --
WEBSITES AND TECHNOLOGY SINCE
WITH -- WITH
DISABILITIES AS YOU KNOW THE LAW
HAS BEEN IN PLACE FOR WELL
DECADES OR SO --
AND THE CHALLENGE HAS BEEN
WHETHER WE HAVE AS A STATE
EXERCISED THE NECESSARY
LEADERSHIP TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
ACTUALLY GETTING TO THE PLACE --
THAT WILL ENSURE THAT ALL OF OUR
STATE AGENCIES AND STATE
ENTITIES WILL IT WILL MAKE THEIR
WEBSITES A AVAILABLE AS YOU KNOW
SO MANY SERVICES NOW --
SO MUCH INFORMATION IS AVAILABLE
ONLINE AND DUH TO NOT MAKE THAT
AVAILABLE TO PERSONS WHO WHO
HAVE DISABILITIES --
RELATE DEPRIVES THEM AS THEY ARE
OF THE OPPORTUNITY --
TO ACCESS --
THE IMPORTANT STATE SERVICES AND
SO FOR THAT REASON WE WOULD --
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE I WOULD ALSO
JUST LIKE TO THANK STAFF FOR THE
EFFORTS THAT THEY WENT THROUGH
IN MAKING I THINK TO SAY --
BETTER BILL FOR US.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE.
JEFF HOME OF THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF ONE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS --
ARE RATHER THAN REITERATE WHAT
HAS ALREADY BEEN SAID I'LL JUST
MENTION THAT.
ON THIS BILL IS VERY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE IT WILL HELP INSURE THAT
WE ARE ABLE TO NUMBER.
ONE MEET FEDERAL GUIDELINES THAT
WILL ENSURE COMPLY.
WITH STATE AND FEDERAL LAW.
GUIDELINES THAT ALREADY EXISTS
AND THAT CAN RELATIVELY EASILY
BE MET IF STAFF ARE AWARE OF
THEM AND HAVE THE EXPERTISE TO
IMPLEMENT THEM AND THOSE ARE
REALLY THE TWO PROBLEMS.
BUT THIS BILL CAN ADDRESS BY
HAVING INDIVIDUALS.
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY WHERE THEY SHOULD BE
TO GUY OF STATE AGENCY STAFF
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA WE CAN
FINALLY.
COME TO THE TIME WHEN ALL
INFORMATION AND SERVICES.
A CAN BE ACCESSED BY PERSONS
WITH DISABILITIES THROUGH ONLINE.
OTHER WEBSITES ANOTHER ONLINE
METHODOLOGIES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND WE ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WHO LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
PLEASE COME FORWARD
.
CLINTONIAN CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF
THE BLIND AND I DEFINITELY
SUPPORT BILL THIRTEEN NINETY SIX
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE.
ARE THERE ADDITIONAL WITNESSES.
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
SEEING NINE OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
CNN.
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SCENE NINE I WANT TO THANK OF
THE SENATOR FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD ALSO --
LET ME ALSO ACKLEY COMMENTS MADE
EARLIER AND THAT IS IT JUST.
VERY IMPORTANT FOR US. TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR STATE AGENCIES TO
COMPLY WITH THE OUR REQUIREMENTS
ACCESSIBILITY OR OTHERWISE AND
AND UP THIS IS ONE GOOD WAY OF
DOING IT.
ARM.
I UNDERSTAND THERE'S ANOTHER
BILL A BONTA BUILT THAT IS SO
ALSO --
TENDS TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
SAME SAME ISSUES SO I'M GONNA
ASK THE SENATE TO TO LOOK TO SEE
IF THERE'S ANY OUR CONFLICT
BETWEEN YOUR BUILDING ALSO A
MISTER BONTA SPILL.
I UNDERSTAND BUT MISSED BAKER
ALSO -- HAS
A BILL LAST YEAR'S FOR ON SO I
THINK THAT ALSO ATTEMPTED TO
ADDRESS SOME SUMMER ISSUES SO I
LIKE TO ASK YOU TO LOOK INTO --
THOSE TWO BILLS TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY CONFLICTS THERE SAY
WITHOUT US SEEING NO ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS ARE WHICH
LIKE TO CLOSE.
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT THE
COMMITTEE HAS PROPOSED SOME
AMENDMENTS.
CORRECTLY YES BUDGET AND I'M
WILLING TO ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS
TO CLARIFY THE PURPOSE AND
OBLIGATIONS OF THE NAY OFFICE
ENSURE CONSISTENCY TO THE
TERMINOLOGY USED.
SECOND TO REMOVE THE PUBLIC
REPORTING REQUIREMENT OF
NONCOMPLIANT OFFICES IN FAVOR OF
AN UPDATE OF THE STATE'S
COMPLIANCE.
WHAT THE SENSIBILITY STANDARDS
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGIES EXISTING ANNUAL IT
REPORT?
AND THIRD TO ENSURE THAT THE
LIST OF STATUTES AND STANDARDS
ARE USED CONSISTENTLY THROUGHOUT
THE BILL IN EXISTING LAW AND
MAKE THEIR CLARIFYING CHANGES.
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK TO
HELP ME MAKE THIS A BETTER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE STILL DO
NOT HAVE A QUORUM AND THAT WILL
TAKE UP YOUR ITEM WHEN WE DO
HAVE A QUORUM.
SO THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I NOTICE OF SENATOR DODD IS HERE
I STILL LIKE TO INVITE HIM TO UP
TO THE WITNESS TABLE.
AND PRESENT HIS BILL TODAY HE IS
PRESENTING ARE SP NINE EIGHTY
ONE AND THAT'S ITEM THREE ON THE
AGENDA.
WELCOME SENATOR DODD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
CURRENT LAW SPECIFIES THAT WHEN
A CUSTOMER WISHES TO PURCHASE A
WATER TREATMENT SYSTEM FOR THEIR
HOME.
AND THEY SIGNED A CONTRACT WITH
THE SELLER NO WATER TREATMENT
DEVICE OR MATERIALS MAY BE
DELIVERED AND NO SERVICES MAY BE
PERFORMED UNTIL THE VERY END OF
THE THREE DAY RIGHT TO BE.
SEN PERIOD EXPIRES.
THIS BILL WOULDALLOW FOR THE
INSTALLATION OF WATER TREATMENT
DEVICES DURING THE THREE DAY
RIGHT TO RE SAID PERIOD.
ONLY WHEN REQUESTED BY THE
CUSTOMER.
WATER TREATMENT COMPANIES UNLIKE
OTHER -- AT
SIMILAR DOOR TO DOOR SALES
INDUSTRIES ARE UNIQUELY SINGLED
OUT WITH THIS THREE DAY
PROHIBITION AGAINST INSTALLATION.
WHILE THE OTHER.
SALES INDUSTRY OR ARE HELD TO
THE SAME THREE DAY RIGHT TO
RECEIVE AND CONSUMER PROTECTION
STATUTE.
THEY'RE NOT PROHIBITED FROM
DELIVERING MATERIALS OR
INSTALLATION DURING THIS TIME
PERIOD.
S. B. NINETY ONE CREATES PARITY
IN THE APPLICATION OF THE LAW
FOR WATER TREATMENT COMPANIES.
FURTHER THE BILL STRENGTHENS
EXISTING LAW REQUIRING THE
SELLER OF THE PRODUCT TO BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR ALL COSTS IN
REMOVING THE INSTALLED WATER
TREATMENT DEVICE WITHIN TWENTY
DAYS OF CANCELED BY CUSTOMER.
AND THE SELLER MUST ALSO RESTORE
THE PREMISES TO ITS ORIGINAL
CONDITION.
I HAVE BUT JOSIAH YOUNG HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE SPONSOR OF THE
PACIFIC WATER QUALITY
ASSOCIATION TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH EFFORTS WHEN
HIS PLACE BUT YOU SENATOR THANK
YOU --
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS I'M JUST
SHY YOUNG I'M HALFOF THE
PACIFIC WATER QUALITY
ASSOCIATION.
AWARE THE SPONSORS OF THIS
MEASURE IN TO BE TREATED AS THE
OTHER LICENSE CATEGORIES --
UNDER THE PURVIEW OF THE STATE
CONTRACTOR LICENSING BOARD ARE
TREATED --
AS SENATOR DODD INDICATED AND
WHERE BOMB URGING YOUR YES IN
SUPPORT ON THIS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OUR NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
ABOUT MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS RICHARD MARCUSSEN ON
BEHALF OF THE PLUMBING HEATING
COOLING CONTRACTORS OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA CHAPTERS OF
ASSOCIATED BUILDERS AND
CONTRACTORS.
IN STRONG SUPPORT A AND NOT ONLY
OF OUR MEMBERS ARE PREPARED TO
ABIDE BY THE STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS OF THE LAW BUT THE
INTENT AS WELL.
I KNOW WHEN IN OUR INDUSTRY IS
LOOKING FOR A BLACK EYE WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR CUSTOMERS
ARE SATISFIED WITH THE EQUIPMENT
OR IF FOR WHATEVER REASON THEY
DECIDE THAT.
IT'S NOT THE THE RIGHT OF FIT
FOR THEM DURING THE THREE DAY
RECISION PERIOD A TO RESTORE THE
PROPERTY 21100% OF ITS A A
STATUS BEFORE THE INSTALLATION
WAS MADE WE SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SEEN AN OPPOSITION.
JUST FOR THE RECORD I LIKE TO
NOTE THAT THE COMMUNITY DID
RECEIVE A OUR LETTER OF
OPPOSITION AS OF YESTERDAY.
ARE FROM THE CONTRACTORS STATE
LICENSE BOARD ARE.
ALWAYS.
WE DO APPRECIATE THE INPUT FROM
THE BOARD.
OF A GIVEN THE FACT THAT THE
LETTER WAS RECEIVED WELL AFTER
THE DEADLINE IS NOT REFLECTED IN
THE COMEDIAN ALICE'S.
AND JUST.
OF FORWARD THE INFORMATION OF
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THAT
THE LETTER BASICALLY --
MAKES THE POINT THAT THE BILL
CAN WHO CONFUSES THE LICENSE
REQUIREMENTS FOR LICENSEES AND
AND CONSUMERS BUT BUT AS FAR AS
THE CAN.
AND I THINK WERE TOTALLY FINE
WITH THE PROVIDING DOT CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS ARE LIKE TO ASK THE
AUTHOR TO MAKE SURE YOU IF YOU
DIDN'T RECEIVE A COPY OF THE
LETTER YOU DO HAVE.
THIS CHAIR WAS IT VERY GOOD
THOUGH SO HAVING SAID THAT SO
LET ME OPEN IT UP FOR QUESTIONS
AND COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SCENE NINE SO ON WHICH I CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WHEN WE
DO A QUORUM THEN WILL TAKE A FEW
BILLION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
GOD.
THAT SET OF STANDARDS
[inaudible]
THEN.
SO GOT A SYSTEM DOWN PAT.
ARE A
BUT WAITING FOR OTHER
MEMBERS SENATORS.
MISTER KILEY HAS A BILL TO
PRESENT SO AT THIS TIME I TO A
TURN IT OVER TO HIM AND HE HAS
ITEM NUMBER ONE ACR
.
TWO ONE FIVE A TIME YOU'RE READY
YOU MAY PROCEED.
SHARON MEMBERS HAVE TODAY
[inaudible]
WE ARE.
WE SHOULD FIRST BE A SOMEWHAT
SYMBOLS ASGUIDING VALUES FOR
THE DEVELOPMENT OF ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE.
IN JUST THE LAST FEW YEARS
SEVERAL BREAKTHROUGHS IN THE
APPLICATION OF ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE HAVE UNDERSCORED
THE TECHNOLOGY'S POTENTIAL FOR
ECONOMIC.
AND SOCIAL IMPACT.
IN MARCH OF TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
GOOGLE DEEP MINES ALPHA GO BEAT
THE WORLD'S REIGNING GO CHAMPION
[inaudible]
USING TACTICS SEATED IN
SOPHISTICATION AND ELEGANCE
STRATEGIES DEVELOPED OVER TWO
MILLENNIA.
OF HUMAN EXPERIENCE.
IN NOVEMBER OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN
TESLA ANNOUNCED THAT ITS
VEHICLES HAVE COLLECTIVELY
DRIVEN OVER THREE HUNDRED
MILLIONMILES USING AUTONOMOUS
STEERING AND NAVIGATION
SURPASSING BY UP 240% THE SAFETY
RECORD.
OF HUMAN DRIVE OOPS.
AND JUST LAST MONTH GOOGLE
UNVEILED A NEW TYPE OF A HIGH A
SYSTEM WHICH USES LANGUAGE
INDISTINGUISHABLE FROM THAT OF A
NATIVE SPEAKER TO MAKE
RESERVATIONS.
BOOK FLIGHTS AND SCHEDULE
MEETINGS OVER THE PHONE.
THIS IS JUST THE BEGINNING.
OVER THE NEXT FEW YEARS
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE IS
POISED TO DISRUPT DOMAINS THAT
INCLUDE HEALTHCARE LAW FINANCE
MANUFACTURING.
AND EDUCATION.
IN EACH AREA A AYE CARRIES THE
POTENTIAL TO DRAMATICALLY
IMPROVE ECONOMIC PROSPERITY AND
HUMAN WELL BEING SO LONG AS IS
DEVELOPED IN A MANNER THAT
ENSURES SECURITY.
RELIABILITY AND CONFIDENCE WITH
HUMAN VALUES.
THE PURPOSE OF TODAY'S
RESOLUTION.
IS TO IDENTIFY A SET OF SHARED
VALUES THAT CAN UNDERPIN
COOPERATION BETWEEN POLICYMAKERS
A AYE RESEARCHERS.
AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS AS WE
WORK TOGETHER TO UNLEASH THE
POSITIVE POTENTIAL OF ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE.
THERE'S PERHAPS NO BETTER
VEHICLE FOR THIS THAN THE
ASILOMAR PRINCIPLES.
THE PRINCIPLES WERE DEVELOPED
HERE IN CALIFORNIA AT THE
CONVENTION SITE NEAR PACIFIC
GROVE THAT IS THEIR NAMESAKE --
HERE IN JANUARY OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN OF THE WORLD'S LEADING
A AYE RESEARCHERS ECONOMISTS
LEGAL SCHOLARS AND PHILOSOPHERS
MET TO DISCUSS HOW BEST TO
ENSURE A AYE AYES DEVELOPS
SAFELY [inaudible]
AND ADEQUATE.
THE RESULT OF THEIR COOPERATION.
OR TWENTY THREE PRINCIPLES.
PUT BRIEFLY THESE PRINCIPLES
STRESS THE NEED FOR SAFETY
STANDARDS COOPERATION AMONG A
AYE RESEARCHERS AND POLICY
MAKERS TRANSPARENCY PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS AND ALIGNMENT.
WITH HUMAN VALUES.
MANY OF THESE PRINCIPLES HAVE
PARTICULAR RELEVANCE TO THE WORK
OF THIS COMMITTEE.
SUCH AS THE PRINCIPLE THAT
PEOPLE SHOULD HAVE THE RIGHT TO
ACCESS MANAGE AND CONTROL THE
DATA THEY GENERATE.
GIVEN A AYE SYSTEMS POWER TO
ANALYZE AND UTILIZE THAT DATA.
THE ASILOMAR PRINCIPLES HAVE
BEEN INDEPENDENTLY ENDORSED BY
MORE THAN TWELVE HUNDRED LEADING
EXPERTS IN THE FIELD OF A AYE.
INCLUDING STEPHEN HAWKING YOU ON
MUSK AND DENNIS.
HAS ABA A SOB EXPOUNDER OF DEEP
MIND.
HE BY ENDORSING THESE PRINCIPLES
TODAY THE LEGISLATURE WILL MAKE
AN IMPORTANT FIRST STEP IN
RECOGNIZING SHARED VALUES.
THAT CAN BE APPLIED TO RESEARCH
DEVELOPMENT AND LONG TERM
PLANNING.
I'M HERE TODAY WITH --
TO EXPERT WITNESSES.
PROFESSOR ANTHONY GEARY TEACHES
PHYSICS AT UC SANTA CRUZ IN
ALONG WITH MIT PROFESSOR MAX
TEGMARK IS A FOUNDER OF THE
FUTURE OF LIFE INSTITUTE.
THE FUTURE OF LIFE INSTITUTE A
THINK TANK DEDICATED TO A AYE
SAFETY RESEARCH AS THE SPONSOR
OF THIS RESOLUTION.
JERRY THE LAW IS A FORMER
RESEARCHER IN ROBOTICS AND
MACHINE LEARNING AND NOW SERVES
AS THE TECHNOLOGY POLICY
DIRECTOR OF THE ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH JEFFERSON
WHEN HIS PLEASE WELCOME GOOD
AFTERNOON.
I'M ANTHONY GEARY PROFESSOR OF
PHYSICS AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AT SANTA CRUZ.
AND CO FOUNDER AND CO DIRECTOR
OF THE FUTURE OF LIFE INSTITUTE
WHICH HAS MENTIONED--
ADDRESSES.
SOCIETY SHAPING NEW TECHNOLOGY
SUCH AS ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE
AS WE'VE HEARD ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE AND MACHINE
LEARNING ARE SUDDENLY EVERYWHERE.
FROM THE DRIVING DIRECTIONS I
GOT COMING UP HERE THIS MORNING
TO CARS WILL SOON DRIVE
THEMSELVES.
ALONG WITH SYSTEMS THAT
RECOGNIZE SPEECH AND FACES
TRANSLATE DOCUMENTS ORGANIZE
NEWS FEEDS TO FEET GO MASTERS.
EVEN SCIENTIFIC RESEARCH AND SO
ON IN JANUARY OF LAST YEAR THE
INSTITUTE CONVENE A MEETING AND
SO MARK CALIFORNIA. TO BRING
TOGETHER PRIME MOVERS IN A AYE
AND RELATED FIELDS TO DISCUSS AN
URGENT QUESTION.
GIVEN THIS RECENT EXPLOSION IN
CAPABILITY AND ADOPTION OF A AYE.
HOW DO WE ENSURE OVER THE COMING
DECADES AYE AYE AYES NOT JUST
POWERFUL?
AND NOT JUST PROFITABLE BUT
BENEFICIAL.
WE SEARCH FOR THIS GROUP A
PARTICULAR TASK TOGETHER
PROPOSALS REGARDING A AYE POLICY
AND DISTILL THEM INTO A SET OF
PRINCIPLES THE GUY TECHNOLOGISTS
POLICY MAKERS AND OTHERS.
THIS PROCESS I WOULD SAY IT
SUCCEEDED BEYOND OUR
EXPECTATIONS RESULTING IN TWENTY
THREE PRINCIPLES IS LISTED IN
THE RESOLUTION.
I WITH EXCELLENT CONSENSUS ON
THEM.
THEY BROAD SUPPORT AS WE'VE
HEARD FROM THE HEADS OF A AYE
RESEARCH A COMPANIES INCLUDING
GOOGLE DE MINED FACEBOOK OPEN A
AYE GOOGLE BRAIN.
APPLE AND OVER A THOUSAND MORE A
AYE RESEARCHERS AS WELL AS
LEADERS IN THE CALIFORNIA TECH
INDUSTRY LIKE YOU ON MOSQUEIN
SAM ALTMAN AND ACADEMICS FROM
THE LATE STEPHEN HAWKING. TO A
AYE PIONEER STUART RUSSELL AND
PETER NORFOLK ALSO CALIFORNIANS.
PART OF WHAT MAKES THIS
CONSENSUS POSSIBLE I THINK IS
THAT MANY OF THESE PRINCIPLES
ARE ALMOST SELF EVIDENTLY
DESIRABLE.
WE ALL WANT AND I SYSTEMS THAT
ARE SAFE THAT ARE UNDERSTANDABLE
THE RESPECT OUR LIBERTY AND
PRIVACY AND RIGHTS.
SUPPORT OUR SHARED PROSPERITY
MITIGATE RISKS AND KEEP US
HUMANS IN THE DRIVER'S SEAT.
WE ALL KNOW THAT THESE DESIRES
ARE FAR FROM SELF FULFILLING
SAFE TECHNOLOGIES DON'T HAPPEN
BY THEMSELVES PRIVACY IS NOT
AUTOMATICALLY RESPECTED.
CIVIC PROCESSES ARE NOT
INHERENTLY IMMUNE FROM
SUBVERSION.
ENSURING THAT LOOK BENEFIT OF
TECHNOLOGY TAKES ACTIVE EFFORT
AND PARTICIPATION FROM
RESEARCHERS DEVELOPERS POLICY
MAKERS SUCH AS YOURSELVES AND
THE PUBLIC.
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN AND WILL BE
THE BIRTHPLACE OF MANY CUTTING
EDGE INFORMATION TECHNOLOGIES
INCLUDING AYE AYE.
IT WAS POSSIBLE IN VITAL FOR
CALIFORNIA TO TAKE THE LEAD ALSO
AND HOW THOSE TECHNOLOGIES CAN
BE USED FOR THEIR ULTIMATE
PURPOSE. TO BETTER HUMANS LIVES
AND SOCIETIES FUNCTIONING.
LIKE YOU SAW MY PRINCIPLES IT
ENDORSES THIS PRINT THIS
RESOLUTION DOES NOT OF COURSE BY
ITSELF REQUIRE ANYONE TO DO
ANYTHING.
RATHER WE HOPE IT WILL INSPIRE
SIMILAR ACTIONS ELSEWHERE.
AND HELP HIGHLY THESE PRINCIPLES
A SET OF CORE ASPIRATIONS TO
HELP A AYE REVOLUTION HAPPENED
IN ITS BENEFICIAL AWAY AS
POSSIBLE FOR ALL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
TAKE IMAGINEXT WHEN HIS PLACE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JEREMY
KULA -- HAS --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KILEY SAID I'M A
TECHNOLOGIST AND TAKE POLICY
DIRECTOR AT THE ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION --
PRIOR TO JOINING YET THAT I
RECEIVE MY PHD IN COMPUTER
SCIENCE FROM STANFORD WHERE MY
RESEARCH FOCUSED ON HOW TO
GUARANTEE SAFETY FOR MACHINE
LEARNING SYSTEMS.
PART OF THAT IRON MY BACHELORS
DEGREE AT ANOTHER GREAT
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL CAL TECH --
WHERE I SPENT MY SUMMERS DOING
RESEARCH ON AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES?
NOW PART OF MY AND IT EFF IS THE
WAY A AYE SYSTEMS WILL IMPACT
PRIVACY AND CIVIL LIBERTIES.
WHEN THE UP THAT WAS FOUNDED
ALMOST THREE DECADES AGO
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE WAS THE
STUFF OF CYBERPUNK SCIENCE
FICTION STORIES?
NOW A AYE IS A REALITY AND IS
VERY QUICKLY PERMEATING OUR
LIVES FROM THE ALGORITHMS THAT
DETERMINE WHAT ADS WE SEE ONLINE
TO FACE RECOGNITION SYSTEMS TO
THE SOFTWARE THAT DRIVES
AUTONOMOUS CARS AND THAT'S JUST
THE BEGINNING.
THE STATE OF THE ART IS
ADVANCING RAPIDLY.
YEAH I PRESENTS ENORMOUS
OPPORTUNITIES TO MAKE TECHNOLOGY
WORK BETTER FOR SOCIETY BUT IT
ALSO COMES WITH GREAT RISK.
YEAH I SYSTEMS THAT ARE
CAREFULLY DESIGNED OVER A LITTLE
THOUGHT WAS GIVEN TO THE
ACCURACY OF THE TRAINING DATA
USED.
CAN RESULT IN OUTCOMES THAT ARE
UNFAIR OR BIASED.
THIS CAN HAPPEN EVEN IF THE
DESIGNER DIDN'T HAVE MALICIOUS
INTENT.
IN ORDER TO AVOID OUTCOMES LIKE
THIS TECHNOLOGISTS AND LAWMAKERS
NEED TO CAREFULLY THINK THROUGH
HOW THEY'RE DESIGNING AND
DEPLOYING NEW A AYE SYSTEMS AND
HOW THEY WILL BE PUT INTO.
DOCUMENTS LIKE THE ASILOMAR A
AYE PRINCIPLES CAN HELP IN THIS
REGARD.
THEY DON'T PROVIDE ALL THE
ANSWERS BUT THEY DO A VERY GOOD
JOB OF HELPING US FLAG THE SORTS
OF ISSUES WE NEED TO THINK
THROUGH.
MANY OF THEM MAY SEEM OBVIOUS
BUT WE HAVE ALREADY SEEN
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE THESE
FUNDAMENTAL PRINCIPLES HAVE BEEN
MISSED BY THOSE DEVELOPING AND
DEPLOYING A AYE SYSTEMS.
THESE PRINCIPLES REPRESENT A
STEP FORWARD IN THE RESPONSIBLE
DEVELOPMENT TODAY I AND WILL
HELP US ENSURE THAT A AYE
BENEFITS BENEFITS US ALL AS WE
ENTER THE SCIENCE FICTION FUTURE.
THANK YOU KNOW THE COURT YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CHAU
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL PLEASE COME FORWARD.
SEEN AN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE LET'S BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE MISTER CALDERON GO
AHEAD --
ONES ARE YOU FOR BRINGING THE
RESOLUTION FOR MY OFFICE IS
ACTUALLY BEEN LOOKING AT INTO
ISSUES REGARDING ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE --
YOU KNOW RECENTLY ALONG MOSQUE --
PAID FOR US OUR DOCUMENTARY TO
BE ONLINE FOR A LITTLE WHILE
IT'S CALLED THE TRUSSES COMPUTER
AND OF ANY OF YOU HAVE BEEN AT
AT OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THAT IT TALKS ABOUT ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE IN THE DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE
IS PROGRAMMING CODE ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE.
YOU KNOW LIKE CERTAIN COMMANDS
AND THEN THERE'S A THOMAS.
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE IS FREE
THINKING I THINK THE CONCERN
THAT I HAVE RIGHT NOW IS THAT WE
HAVE STE COMPANIES THAT ARE --
NOT REALLY STOPPING TO THINK
ABOUT IS OF WORKING ON
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE --
AND AT ANY POINT TIME COULD
RELEASE A COMPLETELY INDEPENDENT
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENT BEING
OVER THE NETWORK AND ONCE IT'S
OUT THERE THERE'S NO THERE'S NO
STOPPING IT.
THERE IS NO ON OFF BUTTONTO ANY
TYPE OF ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE
ONCE IT'S ONCE PERMEATED
THROUGHOUT OUR NETWORKING
THROUGHOUT OUR SYSTEM THERE'S NO
STOPPING IT OTHER THAN STE.
MAYBE SHUTTING DOWN THE ENTIRE
SYSTEM WHICH A IS NOT REALLY
FEASIBLE POWER NOT POSSIBLE LOT
OF PEOPLE WOULD BE HURT BY THAT
AND I I I I STILL QUESTION THE
THE REALITY BEING ABLE TO DO
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
SO ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE I
THINK IS SOMETHING THAT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BEING THAT
WE ARE THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY
IN THE WORLD WE ARE THE HOME TO
THE TECH INNOVATION SECTOR.
AND PEOPLE ARE LOOKING AT US
WORLDWIDE TO SEE WHAT WE DO ON
THESE ISSUES IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE SPEND A LOT OF
TIME AND A LOT OF ENERGY
FOCUSING ON THIS BECAUSE WE
DON'T KNOW GOOGLE'S DOING BEHIND
THE SCENES RIGHT NOW OTHER
COMPANIES DO BEHIND THE SCENES
RIGHT.
NOW THAT COULD POTENTIALLY
UNLEASH AN ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENT BEING THROUGHOUT OUR
NETWORK AND ONCE IT'S OUT THERE
AGAIN WE HAVE NO ABILITY THERE'S
NO ON AND OFF SWITCH IT'S IT.
IT'S DONE AND SO I THINK YOU I'M
I'M NOT FAMILIAR WITH THAT WITH
THE PRINCIPLES I APPRECIATE THE
RESOLUTIONS AND I CAN I CAN I GO
IN AND SPEND SOME MORE TIME
LOOKING OUT THE PRINCIPLES
ACTUALLY DO BUT IT REALLY IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE PUT A LOT OF
TIME.
AND ENERGY OUT INTO THE SUBJECT
MATTER BECAUSE IT'S GOING TO
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACT OUR LIVES
OF PEOPLE DON'T KNOW AND KNOW
THE DIFFERENCE AND AGAIN.
YOU KNOW THE TECHNOLOGY THAT HAS
BEEN USING THAT AS MORE COATED
TO GIVE A CERTAIN COMMAND --
LIKE.
I SEARCH FOR THESE THIS TYPE OF
INFORMATION ONLINE AND THEREFORE
I'M EXPOSED TO THAT TYPE OF
INFORMATION ONLINE I THINK
THAT'S ACTUALLY DETRIMENTAL.
I END AND I THINK PART OF WHY WE
ARE SEEING SUCH DIVERSE OF
POLITICAL --
SPEECH OUT THERE RIGHT NOW IS
BECAUSE WERE ONLY BEING FED WHAT
AN ALGORITHM BELIEVES WE SHOULD.
SEE OR WHAT THEY THINK WE WANT
TO SEE WHAT IT'S IMPORTANT TO
SEE OPPOSING POSITIONS IN A BEEN
OPPOSING POINTS OF VIEW SO I
THINK THAT.
IT IS ABSOLUTELY THE PLACE OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO GET
INVOLVED AT LEAST FOR OUR OWN
STATE.
BECAUSE WE ARE LOOKING AT OTHER
PEOPLE LOOKING AT US FOR
LEADERSHIP BUT ALSO TO TO REALLY
PUSH THE ENVELOPE TO ENCOURAGE
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO DO
SOMETHING BECAUSE THERE'S A LACK
OF REGULATION BECAUSE IS LACK OF
UNDERSTANDING IS A LACK OF
INTEREST.
AND IT'S KIND OF THIS --
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE A THING
OF THE MOVIES.
MORE IT IS A REALITY IT IS HERE.
AND WE NEED REAL REGULATION WHEN
MS ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE SO
I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE MEASURE
WHENEVER WE CAN OPPORTUNITY MOVE
AT ALL MOVE IT I WOULD
APPRECIATE YOU ARE BRINGING THE
MEASURE.
FOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
MISTER OBERNOLTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I ALSO
WILL BE SUPPORTING THE
RESOLUTION I I HAD A COUPLE OF
CONCERNS THAT I JUST WANTED TO
VOICE BECAUSE I MEAN THIS IS A
SET OF VALUES THAT WERE ADOPTED
OUT OF THE CONFERENCE AND WE ARE
POLICY BODY.
SO WE WORRY ABOUT HOW THOSE
VALUES TRANSLATE INTO POLICY AND
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT.
WAYS IN WHICH I THINK THAT SOME
OF THE VALUES EXPRESSED IN THIS
RESOLUTION.
NOW AND IN THE CAR OUTPUT OF THE
CONFERENCE ARE GOING TO HAVE
DIFFICULTY GETTING TRANSLATED
INTO POLICY AND I JUST WANTED TO
TALK ABOUT A COUPLE OF THEM.
BOB FIRST FAILURE TRANSPARENCY
IT SAYS IF A NAY I SYSTEM CAUSES
HARM RICHARD PIPE POSSIBLE TO
ASCERTAIN Y. WHICH I TOTALLY
AGREE WITH.
AND THIS IS A REALLY DIFFICULT
THING TO DO WITH ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE BECAUSE BY
DEFINITION A AYE IS A NON I MEAN
IT IT'S IT'S WE DO IT WE
IMPLEMENTED DETERMINISTIC KLAY.
BUT THE OUTCOME OF OF THE NAY
AYE CALCULATION IS NOT
DETERMINISTIC SO.
I IF YOU DO SOMETHING WITH
MACHINE LEARNING THEIR IT'S IT'S
REALLY IMPOSSIBLE TO GO BACK AND
SAY WHY DID YOU MAKE THAT
DECISION IT'S WELL CAN YOU TRAIN
ME ON ALL THESE DIFFERENT DATA
SETS AND I SUMMED UP ALL THESE
WEIGHTS ON THESE DIFFERENT
NEURONS AND THAT'S THE OUTPUT.
THAT I SELECTED AND YOU CAN'T
SAY WELL WHY DID YOU SAY THAT
YOU KNOW --
YOU DID HARM WHAT YOU KNOW WHAT
TO RETRAIN IT RIGHT SO IT IT'S
THIS IS A CRITICALLY CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT.
HOWEVER WE KNOW BY DEFINITION
BECAUSE WERE WERE LYING ON A AYE
TO MAKE THESE LEAPS --
OF OF LOGICAL THINKING ARE BY
DEFINITION WE'RE NEVER GOING TO
BE ABLE TO ACHIEVE THAT EXACTLY --
ANOTHER ONE HAS RESPONSIBILITY
[inaudible]
THE CONFERENCE SAYS THAT
DESIGNERS AND BUILDERS OF A AYE
SYSTEMS ARE STAKEHOLDERS IN THE
MORAL IMPLICATIONS OF THEIR USE
MISUSE AND ACTIONS WITH A
RESPONSIBILITY TO SHAPE THOSE
IMPLICATIONS.
AND THAT IS GREAT AS A VALUE.
OUR I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WERE THINKING ABOUT THE POLICY
IMPACT THOUGH THAT VALUE BECAUSE
IF YOU EQUATE RESPONSIBILITY
WITH LIABILITY.
THEN IT COULD HAVE A VERY
CHILLING IMPACT ON THE
DEVELOPMENT AND THE DEPLOYMENT
OF ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE CAN
IMAGINE IF YOU.
OVER WORD A DEVELOPER OF ANY AYE
SYSTEM AND OUR LEGAL SYSTEM PUT
RESPONSIBILITY FOR EVERY SINGLE
MISTAKE THAT THAT PIECE OF A I
MADE AND ITS ENTIRE COMMERCIAL
LIFETIME ON YOU.
YOU CAN SEE THAT THAT WOULD NOT
BE A COMMERCIALLY VIABLE THING
TO DO.
AND THE LAST THING I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT WAS OTHER VALUES IN
HERE HUMAN VALUES IT SAYS A AYE
SYSTEM SHOULD BE DESIGNED AND
OPERATED.
SO AS TO BE COMPATIBLE WITH THE
IDEALS OF HUMAN DIGNITY RIGHTS
FREEDOMS AND CULTURAL DIVERSITY --
AS A POLICY MAKER I UNDERSTAND
WHAT THOSE ARE.
A IS A COMPUTER SCIENCE I HAVE
NO IDEA WHAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT BECAUSE A I AM EVEN EVEN
THOUGH IT IS ANTHROPOGENIC IT IS
NOT ANTHROPOMORPHIC.
THEY AYE SYSTEMS LOOK AND THINK
NOTHING LIKE HUMANS DO AND TO
THE EXTENT THAT IT A AYE HOUSE
IN RESPECT VALUES.
IT'S ONLY TO THE EXTENT THAT WE
PROGRAM IT TO DO THAT.
AND I'M NOT EVEN SURE HOW YOU
WOULD TRANSLATE THAT INTO POLICY
ADMIN IF YOU'RE DESIGNING A SORT
OF A AYE. TO TO TRY AND FIGURE
OUT WHAT LIFE EXPECTANCY IS FOR
LIFE INSURANCE ACTUARIAL TABLES
FOR EXAMPLE.
HOW WOULD YOU ANSWER THE
QUESTION AS IT RESPECTING
CULTURAL DIVERSITY WHEN IT DOES
THAT?
SO I I JUST WANT TO CAUTION US
THAT IT'S IT'S GREAT TO ADOPT
THESE IDEALS BUT WE NEED TO BE
VERY VERY CAREFUL AS WE
TRANSLATE THEM INTO POLICY TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE DOING IT IN
WAYS THAT ARE WORKABLE AND THAT
ARE USEFUL.
SO SORRY FOR THE MONARCH KNOW
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DO YOU KNOW
IT'S COUNT ON A FELLOW EYE
CONTACT GRAD TO STIR THE POT OF
THE MINNESOTA.
THAT'S WHAT WE DO --
AYE I I I I I THINK THERE'S A
GREAT POINTS I AM I DON'T THINK
OUR INTENTION IS TO SAY THAT
EACH OF THESE PRINCIPLES
NECESSARILY HAS A A POLICY
QUARREL IT --
OR CONCRETE POLICY THAT I THINK --
MORE THE THINKING IS THAT --
I YOU KNOW IN THE COMING YEARS
ADVANCEMENTS AND I ARE GONNA --
YOU KNOW I TRANSFORM THE WAY WE
APPROACH PERHAPS EVERY POLICY
AREA AT THAT WE DEAL WITH THAT
AT THE CAPITOL HERE AND SO I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT --
WE AT LEAST START TO KIND OF
THINK ABOUT THAT IN THESE
PRINCIPLES I THINK PROVIDE US A
REALLY GOOD BASIS TECH KIND OF
GROUND THAT THOUGHT PROCESS AND
DISCUSSION IN THAT ARE OF YOU.
ANYONE THAT --
YEAH I WOULD JUST AGREE WITH
THAT IN THAT --
THESE PRINCIPLES AS ENVISIONED
BY THE PEOPLE WHO ARE WRITING
THE MORE.
I THINK DID NOT HAVE THE
INTENTION OF EACH ONE WOULD
TRANSLATE INTO A POLICY BUT SOME
OF THEM MIGHT TRANSLATE INTO
OTHER THINGS FOR EXAMPLE.
YOU BROUGHT UP THE ISSUE OF
FAILURE TRANSPARENCY AND EXPLAIN
ABILITY AND I SYSTEMS WHICH IS.
AS YOU MENTIONED TERRIBLE AT THE
MOMENT YOU SORT OF THERE'S NO
ANSWER TO WHY DID YOU DO THAT
OTHER THAN.
THOSE WITH IT THAT WAY TO MY
NARAL NETWORK SAID BUT THAT IS A
RESEARCH PROGRAM OF LOOKING FOR
HOW TO CREATE MACHINE LEARNING
SYSTEMS THAT DO HAVE SOME LEVEL
OF TRANSPARENCY AND EXPLAIN
ABILITY SO.
HAVING A CAN ENCOURAGE
INVESTMENTS AND EFFORT PUT INTO
RESEARCH THAT ON THE TECHNICAL
SIDE BRING SOME OF THOSE
CAPABILITIES INTO BEING AND THEN.
IF THERE IS A TECHNICAL
CAPABILITY DO IT THEN YOU CAN
THINK OF IS THEIR POLICY THAT
THEY COULD ENCOURAGE THAT ARE
EVEN REQUIRED IN SOME
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE SAY SAFETY
WAS VERY CRITICAL OR SOMETHING --
SO I THINK THE SOME OF THEM MAY
TRANSLATE MORE LESS DIRECTLY IN
A POLICIES BUT OTHERS ARE MORE
ASPIRATIONAL GOALS IT MIGHT
MIGHT ENCOURAGE RESEARCH OR
MIGHT ENCOURAGE --
A AYE RESEARCHERS THEMSELVES TO
THINK DIFFERENTLY ABOUT THINGS
THAT WOULD IT'S IT'S COVERING
ALL THOSE DIFFERENT FACES I
WOULD SAY. FOR NOW I I REALIZE
THAT AND I UNDERSTAND THAT THAT.
THE INTENTION WAS NOT TO
TRANSLATE DIRECTLY INTO POLICY
HOWEVER I JUST WANTED TO CAUTION
EVERYONE BECAUSE WE ARE ADOPTING
AND SUPPORTING IT THAT WE NEED
TO START THINKING ABOUT HOW THEY
WILL GET TRANSLATE INTO POLICY.
BECAUSE IN FUTURE YEARS WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO GRAPPLE WITH THAT
ISSUE.
I THINK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
SEEING NINE THAT WAS NICE OF
VERY NICE EXCHANGE AND I WANNA
THANK GOD THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS ACR FORD.
AND ARE YOU MAY RECALL THAT --
BACK IN MARCH WE WE THE
COMMITTEE HAD A HEARING ON
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE WHERE WE
INVITED OUT.
OF VARIOUS STAKEHOLDERS TO BE A
PART OF IT AND INCLUDING OF
INDUSTRY FOLKS --
ACADEMIA AS WELL AS LABOR FOLKS
THAT YOU TO EXPLORE SOME OF THE
IS THAT MAYBE IT THAT MAY BE
FORTHCOMING.
AND THAT WAS A VERY PRODUCTIVE --
HEARING AND DUCKS ARE OUT THERE
AFTER I HAD A CHANCE TO BE PART
OF ANOTHER BECAUSE CONFERENCE IN
FACT --
WITHOUT FOLKS FROM OTHER OTHER
COUNTRY AND WHERE I LEARNED --
FROM ARE THESE OTHER --
PEOPLE THAT THEY WERE HEAVILY
AND INVESTING IT INTO A AYE AS
WELL.
AND THEY ALWAYS ALWAYS WANTED TO
KNOW WHAT CALIFORNIA'S DOING AND
YOU KNOW SO I HAD A CHANCE TO
KIND OF SHARE SOME OF THE IDEAS
WITH THEM --
BUT ARE I THINK WE'RE ON THE
RIGHT TRACK AND ALL THE DE R.
THE AMOUNT OF WORK THAT WE DOING
HERE I THINK REFLECTS --
ADOT ALSO I THINK I'M I'M I WANT
TO THANK YOU BOTH GENTLEMEN FOR
BEING HERE BECAUSE I THINK THERE
IS A LOT MORE THAT WE CAN DO
TOGETHER --
IDEA FROM FROM OUR POLICY
ASSEMBLY AND WORKING WITH
ACADEMIA ARE AS WELL AS THE
INDUSTRY SO I LOOK FOR TO
CONTINUING WORKING WITH YOU
FOLKS ARE.
AND THAT TOO HE SAID WE CAN
COOPERATE WE WANT TO DO THAT SO
WE THOUGHT I'D LIKE TO YASSER --
CHAIR VICE CHAIR KIND CLOSING
COMMENTS.
HOW THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
APPRECIATE THAT THE THE COMMENTS
AND DISCUSSION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I?
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ONCE WE HAVE
QUORUM IT'S ONE TWO THREE FOUR
FIVE WE WE I SEE MISS BAKER
JOINING US SO WE WILL ESTABLISH
QUORUM.
SO I THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR FOR
BEING A GENTLEMAN AND WE WILL.
ESTABLISH [inaudible]
ONE YEAH REGARDLESS [inaudible]
CHAO HERE [inaudible]
KILEY HERE [inaudible]
BAKER [inaudible]
BERMAN CALDERON [inaudible]
GABRIEL.
IRWIN.
MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE.
REYES.
SO WOULD I LIKE TO ENTERTAIN A
MOTION --
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED TO
AMEND SECRETARY PLEASE FOR ALL.
MOTION HAS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
CHAO TIE SO.
KILEY AYE KILEY AYE BAKER.
BAKER AYE BERMAN CALDERON.
CALDERON AYE GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN MULLIN OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE AYE REYES.
HERE BILL IS OUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND YOUR YOU ENTERTAINING ANY
MOTIONS FOR THE PREVIOUS BILLS
YES I WILL LET'S DO THAT RIGHT
NOW THANK YOU FOR THE REMINDER
LET'S LET'S JUST GO DOWN THE
LIST --
LET'S GO TO ITEM NUMBER THREE
AND THAT'S S. B. NINE EIGHTY ONE
THAT'S DOT BELL DO I HAVE A
MOTION.
THE BILL TO MOVED AND SECONDED
THAT SECRETARY PLEASE CALL ROW.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CHAO
AYE CHAU AYE KILEY [inaudible]
BAKER.
BERMAN CALDERON.
CALDERON AYE GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN MULLIN OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE AYE REYES.
THAT BILL HAS FOR VOTE SO I WILL
LEAVE THAT OPEN.
NEXT SO LET'S GO TO ITEMS SEVEN
AND THAT'S AS BE THIRTEEN FIFTY
FIVE HILL.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL.
MOTION AS DO PASSED TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CHAO HIGH CHAU AYE
KILEY.
BAKER [inaudible]
BERMAN.
CALDERON CALDERON AYE GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN MULLIN OBERNOLTE
OBERNOLTE AYE REYES [inaudible]
FOR THAT BILL ALSO HAS A FOR
VOLATILITY LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR
FLORA ADDITIONAL MEMBERS.
A FINALLY WE HAVE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT SP THIRTEEN NINETY SIX
GALGIANI.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL.
UPS YES IT DOES REMOVE THANK YOU
SECOND IT TARA.
AND SECRETARY PLEASE KALRA.
I'M MUCH DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CHAO TIE CHAU AYE KILEY BAKER.
BERMAN CALDERON.
CALDERON AYE GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN MULLIN OBERNOLTE.
NOW TO YOU KNOW RADIUS.
THAT BILL HAS THREE VOTES THREE
TO ONE SO WILL LEAVE THE REAL
OPEN [inaudible]
OKAY.
SO I LIKE TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION
TO APPROVE THE CONSENT AGENDA.
SO -- MADAM
SECRETARY.
SO THAT WOULD BE ITEMS --
FIVE AND SIX SB ELEVEN NINETY
SIX SAID JACKSON AND ALSO S. B.
TWELVE SEVENTY FOUR MCGUIRE.
AND SECRETARY RECALL PLEASE.
ON SB ELEVEN NINETY SIX TO PASS
TO JUDICIARY COMMITTEE A CHILD
HIGH SHALL I KILEY BAKER.
BERMAN CALDERON.
CALDERON AYE GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN MULLIN OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE I KILEY KILEY AYE.
THAT BILL IS FIVE VOTES WILL
LEAVE THE ROAD OPEN. FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS SHELL AND A NOTICE THAT
A SENATOR HERTZBERG IS HERE
WELCOME SENATOR HERTZBERG AND
YOU HAVE --
ITEM NUMBER FOUR SP ONE THOUSAND
AND ONE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS APPRECIATE
VERY MUCH ARMED.
THIS BILL DEALS WITH THE NOTION
OF BOTS.
WHAT'S A BOT IN BROAD TERMS IT
IS WHERE.
YOU USE A COMPUTER TO FAKE.
THAT YOU'RE A HUMAN BEING THAT
YOUR IMPERSONATING A HUMAN BEING.
AND WE HAVE SEEN THIS BOX.
I HAVE A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT IN A
NUMBER OF ASPECTS OF OUR SOCIETY
THAT MERITS GOVERNMENT
[inaudible]
INVOLVEMENT [inaudible]
WHY?
WE SEEN IN ELECTIONS --
CERTAINLY BONT'S THESE THINGS
THAT YOU THINK ARE PEOPLE ARE
OUT THERE AND CITING IDEAS AND
COMMENTS ARE.
ARE CERTAINLY PEOPLE HAVE THE
RIGHT UNDER THE CONSTITUTION TO
SAY WHAT THEY WANT BUT THE
NOTION IS TO MANIPULATE
ELECTIONS WE SAW ON PARK LAND.
IN THE FIRSTCOUPLE OF HOURS
AFTER THE SHOOTING A SERIES OF
BOTS --
INCITING --
MESSAGING ON BOTH SIDES OFTEN
NOT JUST FOR POLITICAL REASONS
BUT FOR ECONOMIC GAIN I KNOW
THROUGH MY RELATIONSHIPS THAT
THE A NUMBER OF INTERESTS IN
BULGARIA.
USE THIS BECAUSE THE WAY PEOPLE
GET PAID IS THROUGH TRANSFERS
WILL YOU WRITE IN CENTURY
HEADLINES.
AND THEN THAT THE YOU GET SHARES
AND YOU GET PAID FOR ON THE
SHARES.
WE SEEN A A COMPANIES WHERE
SOMEBODY GOES OUT AND WANTS TO
BE A F. FANCY SH NANCY MOVIE
STAR SOMETHING AND THEY GO ON
HIRE A COMPANY THAT SAYS FIND ME
FOLLOWERS.
AND THEY FIND THE MOTHS.
WE KNOW IN MY OWN POLITICAL
CAMPAIGN WHEN I JUST RAN FOR
OFFICE MY OPPONENTS IN A CERTAIN
INDUSTRY CREATED ROBOTS.
AND WE'VE SEEN THE SAME THING.
IN A NUMBER ABOUT IT IN IN
CERTAINLY COMPANIES TO GO TO THE
PUBLIC MARKETS WHERE THEY GET
VALUATIONS AND SAY WE HAVE A
HUNDRED THOUSAND HUNDRED MILLION
FOLLOWERS WHEN THEY REALLY DON'T.
AND WE FURTHER NO FROM FOR THAT
A NIGHT THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN STUDY ESTIMATES AS
MANY AS 15% OF THOSE ACCOUNTS ON
TWITTER AREN'T HUMAN BEINGS
[inaudible]
THEIR BOTS.
WE GO SIXTY MILLION PEOPLE ON
FACEBOOK THAT ARE BOTS SO
SIGNIFICANT QUESTION.
SO WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE
IS TO BASICALLY TO TELL THE
TRUTH BILL.
TELL THE TRUTH BILL ARE YOU A
HUMAN ARE YOU A COMPUTER.
ARE YOU GENERATED FOR THAT
PURPOSE THAT'S WHAT THIS BILLS
ABOUT.
NOW WHEN YOU DEAL IN THE ISSUE
OF TRUTH YOU RUN INTO THE FOLLOW
THE CONSTITUTION.
I WOULD SUGGEST THAT WHAT WE
SEEING WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO
THE CREDIBLE STAFF YOU HAVE THIS
COMMITTEE THAT THEY HAVE TAKEN
IN THE QUE TORTURED VIEW OF THE
CONSTITUTION.
FROM SOMEBODY WHO HAS SPENT HIS
ENTIRE LIFE IN THAT REGARD.
THE TRICK THAT'S OFTEN PLAYED ON
PEOPLE IS THAT YOU WRITE A
DOCUMENT YOU CITE CASES AND YOU
CITE CASES FOR PROPOSITIONS THAT
ARE BROUGHT PROPOSITIONS THAT
LOOK LIKE THEY'RE REALLY
IMPORTANT CONSTITUTIONAL
PRINCIPLES I WANT TO GIVE YOU A
FEW.
THAT WERE CITED BECAUSE I READ
THE CASES. FOR EXAMPLE IN TALLY
VERSUS CALIFORNIA THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES PASSED AN ORDINANCE.
THAT SAID NO PERSON SHALL
DISTRIBUTE ANY HAND BILL WITHOUT
PUTTING THEIR NAME ON IT.
THE CONSTITUTION PROTECTS
PEOPLE'S RIGHT TO BE ANONYMOUS.
THE FEDERALIST PAPERS IS A
PERFECT EXAMPLE COMMONSENSE IN
THE CONSTITUTION THERE'S A
REASON WHY YOU WANT TO BE
ANONYMOUS.
BUT ANONYMITY ISN'T FRAUD.
YOU CAN SAY WHATEVER YOU WANT IN
THE CONSTITUTION.
YOU CAN IS LAWS NOT YELLING FIRE
IN A CROWDED THEATER BUT YOU
COULD NOT COMMIT FRAUD WE HAVE
IN THIS STE AND AND THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILLS ABOUT FRAUD BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS CODE SECTION.
SEVENTEEN FIVE HUNDRED WHICH IS
REFERENCED HERE TALKS ABOUT ACT
ACTIONS WHICH ARE UNTRUE WERE
MISLEADING.
THE CONSTITUTIONAL LAWS YOU TO
MAKE UP EXAGGERATE TWEET IF
YOU'RE THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
BUT THIS BILL IS NOT ABOUT THAT.
THIS BILL ISN'T SAYS THAT I'M
THOMAS PAINE OR I'M ALEXANDER
HAMILTON THIS BILL SAYS THAT I'M
A COMPANY IN BULGARIA THAT'S
TRYING TO INCITE ACTIVITY.
AND ALL WE'RE SAYING IS IF
YOU'RE A BOT WE'RE TRYING TO
CREATE A PROCESS WHEREBY WE'RE
DEALING WITH THIS THING IN A
THOUGHTFUL INTELLIGENT MANNER.
THAT'S SOMETHING HAPPENS IN THIS
LEGISLATIVE BUILDING THAT I FIND
EXTRAORDINARILY FRUSTRATING.
THE INTEREST GROUPS THAT ARE
NARROW MINDED IN THEIR OWN
LITTLE WAYS TRY TO ENGAGE IN
BEHAVIOR BUT WE SEEN HERE IN
THIS BILL.
IS THE MERGER OF THE LEFT AND
THE RIGHT.
THE CONSERVATIVES WHO WANT
BUSINESS AS USUAL AND DON'T
UPSET MY BUSINESS AND THE
CONSTITUTIONALIST TO TAKE A
TORTURED VIEW IN ADDITION I HAVE
ALL THE OTHER CASES THE MCINTYRE
CASE.
AND THE TURNER BROADCASTING CASE
AND THERE ARE A V. CASE WHICH
WAS A ST PAUL'S CASE THAT DEALT
WITH INCENDIARY LANGUAGE IN
SAINT PAUL WHICH IS NOT WHAT I'M
DEALING WITH IN THIS BILL.
THIS IS ABOUT TELLING THE TRUTH
AND USING THE COMPUTERS TO
MANIPULATE PEOPLE'S LIVES.
NOW BECAUSE OF THE POLITICS OF
THIS BILL THEY HAVE AGREED TO
TAKE THESE AMENDMENTS THAT ARE
NOT HAPPY ABOUT BUT I WANT.
TO COOK THE INCREMENTALLY MOVE
THE STRIKE SECTION SEVENTY NINE
FORTY TWO FROM THE BILL WHICH IS.
GUTS IT PRETTY DRAMATICALLY BUT
I WILL BE BACK.
I AM PERSON OF GREAT --
RESILIENCE AND I WILL PUSH
THROUGH AND DEAL WITH WHAT I'VE
GOT TO DEAL WITH BUT I WANT TO
KEEP THE RECORD CLEAR AND
STRAIGHT ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED
HERE AND WHY.
AND THAT YOU KNOW WHEN WHEN I
THINK THAT IS MORE AND MORE
PEOPLE ARE AFFECTED BY THESE
IMPERSONATIONS THERE'S GOING TO
BE MORE EFFORT TO MOVE THE BALL
FORWARD IN WHAT HAPPENS IN
GOVERNMENT.
WHICH IS QUITE CHALLENGING FOR
ME IS THAT WE WE DON'T GET TO
THINK THROUGH THE FUTURE WE
RESPOND TO WHAT HAPPENS AND SO
THERE WILL BE MORE CONTROVERSIES
THERE WILL BE MORE ARE URGENCY
IS THERE WILL BE MORE --
SCANDALS THAT WILL RESULT IN WHY
WE DON'T DO THIS BUT AT LEAST AS
A BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT.
WE WILL HAVE IN MY VIEW MOVE THE
BALL BY BEGINNING TO IDENTIFY
THIS INSTEAD OF CUTTING AND
RUNNING AT LEAST GETTING IN THE
GAME SUCKS UP THE MEASUREMENTS
WE'RE TRYING TO DEAL WITH THE
ISSUE WHERE PEOPLE PHONY BALONEY
AT UP.
AND LARGE POINT HERE IS TO IT
WHICH YOU HAVE THE MOST ROBUST
CONSTITUTIONAL DISCUSSION BUT
NOT IN A WAY WHERE THE THE THESE
THESE ARGUMENTS ARE MADE ON BOTH
SIDES ONE SIDE WANTING.
TO DE SAY YOU GOT A BILL AND AND
AND AND AND WE DID SOMETHING
ABOUT IT WHEN NOTHING'S DONE.
AND THE OTHER SIDE AN
OVERZEALOUS READING OF THE
CONSTITUTION IN MY JUDGMENT WITH
THAT.
I TURNED OVER TO COMMONSENSE IS
THE SPONSOR OF THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU MEMBERS MY NAME SEAN
PRESTON I'M HERE REPRESENTING
COMMON SENSE MEDIA BUT I'M ALSO
HERE BECAUSE I WAS FORMERLY THE
DIRECTOR OF COMMUNICATIONS FOR
THE CALIFORNIA JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AND I WANT TO TAKE
ONE MOMENT.
AND REMIND EVERYBODY OF THE
PROFOUND NATIONAL SECURITY AMMAN
FORSMAN IMPLICATIONS OF THIS
BILL.
JUST LOOKING AT SOME OF THE
REPORTS WE'VE SEEN IN THE LAST
MONTH ON MAY TWENTY FIRST
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
RESEARCHER PUT OUT A STUDY
FINDING THAT BREXIT.
AND THE TWENTY SIXTEEN
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTIONS COULD
WELL STATISTICALLY HAVE BEEN
TIPPED BY THE MESSAGES PUMPED
OUT BY ILLEGAL BOTS.
ON JUNE TWELFTH OF THIS YEAR
ROBERT MUELLER WHO HAS ALREADY
INDICTED THIRTEEN RUSSIANS FOR
THEIR INTERFERING IN THE
AMERICAN ELECTIONS --
PUT FILING INTO THE FEDERAL
COURT IN WHICH HE SAID THAT
THESE ELECTION INTERFERENCE
EFFORTS CONTINUE WE DON'T KNOW
HOW WE DON'T KNOW.
HOW MUCH --
IN THIS CONTEXT WHERE OUR
DEMOCRACY ITSELF AND WHERE
ELECTIONS ARE SELF ARE BEING
UNDERMINED IT IS WE WOULD
NORMALLY TURN TO WASHINGTON DC
TO FIX THAT BUT THERE IS NO
RATIONAL MIND IN THIS COUNTRY
THAT BELIEVES THAT DONALD TRUMP
IS GOING.
TO TURN ON THE BILLS THAT HELPED
GET HIM ELECTED.
AND SO FOR THE SECURITY OF OUR
DEMOCRACY AND MORE IMPORTANTLY
FOR VOTERS TO HAVE FAITH AND
CONFIDENCE THAT OUR DEMOCRATIC
SYSTEM IS STRONG.
I ASK THAT WE FIND A SOLUTION ON
THIS BILL THIS IS AN URGENT
ISSUE I BELIEVE MOST AMERICANS
MOST CALIFORNIANS WISH THAT THEY
KNEW IF THEY WERE TALKING TO A
BUY OR NOT. ONE FINAL POINT IN
THE TWENTY SIXTEEN ELECTIONS.
A HUNDRED TWENTY SIX MILLION
AMERICANS WERE EXPOSED TO
RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA ON FACEBOOK
FACEBOOK HAS TOLD US THAT.
WE CAN ONLY GUESS WAS WHAT
TWELVE OR THIRTEEN MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WE DON'T EVEN KNOW
THIS IS AN URGENT ISSUE FOR US
TO CONSIDER THANK.
THANKS VERY MUCH NEXT WHEN AS WE
SPEAK.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL PLEASE HOW COME
FORWARD.
SEEING THEN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
DEAR CHAIRMAN SHALL AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE --
AS YOU HEARD BEFORE MY NAME IS
JEREMY GLOW LA I'M TECH POLICY
DIRECTOR AT THE ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION.
TOP FIRST AND FOREMOST WE
APPRECIATE AUTHORS WILLINGNESS
TO LISTEN TO OUR CONCERNS ABOUT
THE IMPACTS SB ONE THOUSAND ONE
AND AS IT WAS BEFORE THE
AMENDMENTS WOULD HAVE HAD ON
FREE SPEECH --
CAUSING PEOPLE SPEECH BE TAKEN
OFFLINE AND CREATING AN
INCENTIVE FOR PEOPLE --
TO BASICALLY TARGET THEIR
ENEMIES ONLINE BY LABELING THEM
AS POTS --
SO WE APPRECIATE THE REMOVAL OF
THE USER REPORTING TAKE DOWN IN
LABELING REGIME AND THE
NARROWING OF THE SCOPE TO THE
PRECISE HARMS AS OPPOSED TO ALL
BOTS -- WE
DO STILL HAVE SOME CONCERNS FOR
EXAMPLE THE INTENT LANGUAGE IN
THE AMENDMENTS REMAINS A LITTLE
BIT CONFUSING TO US --
WE ALSO THINK THE DEFINITION OF
POT COULD BE TIGHTENED UP --
HOWEVER THE THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND THE REMOVAL OF
SECTION SEVENTY NINE FORTY TO DO
GET YOU FF ABOUT. 90% OF THE WAY
TO NEUTRAL --
AND WE WERE ME AND SO WE REMAIN
OPPOSED UNTIL ALL THE DETAILS
ARE WORKED OUT BUT WE DO LOOK
FORWARD TO WORK CONTINUE WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR. TO ACTUALLY
MAKE THIS A STRONG BILL THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU MUCH
NEXT WHEN HIS PLACE.
THANK CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TODAY MY NAME'S KEVIN KINLEY ON
THE TRACTOR.
OF CALIFORNIA GOVERNOR AFFAIRS
FOR INTERNET ASSOCIATION --
I THINK SENATOR HERTZBERG FIRST
BILL IN THE PROCESS AND KEEPING
AN OPEN DOOR FOR US TO EXPRESS
OUR ISSUES IN TERMS OF THE BILL.
THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS --
ONGOING PLATFORMS ROUTINELY
FORCE COMMITTEE STANDARDS TO
SOMETHING THAT WE TAKE VERY
SERIOUSLY HAS BEEN TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF RESOURCES TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT GETS DONE BETTER AND
BETTER EVERYDAY --
AND THE SENATOR HERTZBERG.
OUTLINED IN HIS OPENING.
THAT THIS IS REALLY ABOUT
TELLING THE TRUTH AND PEOPLE NOT
CARING A FRAUDULENT ACTS.
ON THE INTERNET AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE TAKE VERY
SERIOUSLY WE THINK THE
AMENDMENTS.
FOCUS ON THIS ISSUE WELL --
SO WITH THE AMENDMENTS AND
ELIMINATING THE SAME SECTION
SEVENTY NINE FORTY TWO WE LOOK
FORWARD --
TO IRKS ME MOVE TO A NEUTRAL
POSITION AND IT THIS COUPLE
TECHNICAL TWEAKS BUT BOTH JUST
THAT WASN'T HERTZBERG.
SO WILL BE NEUTRAL NOW.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
FELLER INNER FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE WE ARE STILL
IN IN OPPOSITION.
WE NEED TO LOOK AT THE
AMENDMENTS FIRST.
THANK YOU MUCH [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
SEEING NONE LET'S BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE KYLE QUESTION
COMMENTS MISTER OBERNOLTE GUIDE.
I THINK IT WAS CHAIR US SENATOR
I AM ACTUALLY REALLY SUPPORTIVE
OF WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO HERE
I THINK IT'S AN INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT TOPIC THINGS UP BUT I
HAVE SOME BIG CONCERNS ABOUT THE
WAY THAT YOU'VE WORKED AT THE
BILL.
AND AND I'LL JUST GIVE YOU A
COUPLE OF EXAMPLES BUT BASICALLY
MY CONCERN CENTER AROUND.
THE WAY THAT THIS BILL WOULD
LIMIT.
THE APPLICATIONS OF TECHNOLOGY --
TO HUMAN PRODUCTIVITY AND MAKING
HUMAN LIFE BETTER --
AND I DON'T WISH TO FOCUS ON THE
FEELS THAT I'M FAMILIAR WITH YOU
KNOW I'VE HAD A THIRTY YEAR
CAREER AS A VIDEO GAME DESIGNER
AND DO SO.
I WILL GIVE YOU A HYPOTHETICAL
SO YOU KNOW I'M PLAYING A VIDEO
GAME ON MY PC.
WHICH IS CONNECTED TO THE
INTERNET --
I'M WALKING UP I MEAN I'M A
NIGHT NOR THE GUARD RECOGNIZE ME
DRAWS HIS SWORD AND AN EPIC
BATTLE ENSUES.
RIGHT SO THE QUESTION IS IS THAT
A VIOLATION OF YOUR BILL
[inaudible]
NO.
OKAY WELL I DISAGREE WITH YOU
ONLY READ YOU KNOW THIS IS
SECTION. NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE
FORTY ONE WHICH IS NOT THE
SECTION THAT YOU ARE REMOVING IN
YOUR AMENDMENTS IT SAYS IT SHALL
BE UNLAWFUL FOR ANY PERSON TO
USE A BOX. TO COMMUNICATE OR
INTERACT WITH NATURAL PERSONS IN
CALIFORNIA ONLINE WITH THE
INTENTION OF MISLEADING AN
ACTUAL PERSON ABOUT ITS
ARTIFICIAL IDENTITY CORRECT OKAY
SO -- THIS
IS BOUND IT'S NOT CLEAR WHETHER
OR NOT THE GUARD AT THE CASTLE
GATE THAT I'M INTERACTING WITH
IS A POT.
WHAT IS WEEK WE CALLED THE VIDEO
GAME PARLANCE --
AN NPC A NON PLAYER CHARACTER
WORK IS BEING CONTROLLED BY
HUMANS SOMEWHERE ELSE WE HAVE TO
DISCLOSE THAT TO ANYONE IT
CERTAINLY INTERACTING
[inaudible]
WITH US SO I MEAN I WOULD SAY
THAT'S A VIOLATION OF OUR OF THE
BILL.
YOU KNOW IN AND OFTEN WERE
TELLING A STORY IN A VIDEO GAME
THAT'S A VIDEO GAME.
WHO A MISSUS UNLESS I'M JUST
LIKE AND NOT A KID TO PLAY VIDEO
GAMES HER?
AND MASS THAT I TALK TO TOYS AND
BUILDING BLOCKS IN MY DAY BUT
BUT BY ITS NATURE TO VIDEO GAME
YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S NOT A HUMAN
BEING.
IT'S NOT IT'S ARE WHAT WOULD YOU
SAY YOU'RE GOING UP AGAINST THE
GUARD MY KID I WATCH MY KIDS
PLAY THESE GAMES AND YET THERE'S
PEOPLE ON THE OTHER ENDS ARE NOT
ON THE AT OTHER ENDS BUT YOU
KNOW THAT YOU'RE PLAYING THE
GAME VERSES.
IN THE TALKS ABOUT THE IDEA OF
INTENTIONAL MISREPRESENTATION
WITH RICH AS AMENDED IN TERMS OF
THE ISSUE.
ARE ARE SO THE PURPOSE HERE IS
TO INTENTIONALLY MISREPRESENT
WE'RE GOING TO THE POINT THAT
THAT THAT WAS ARTICULATED BY THE
WITNESS AND COMMON SENSE ABOUT.
THAT THE DANGERS HERE
INTENTIONALLY MISREPRESENTING SO
YOU'RE THAT VIDEO GAME OF THE
GUARDS THERE THERE'S NO
INTENTIONAL MISREPRESENTATION IN
ORDER TO TRY TO CAUSE YOU TO
BELIEVE THEY'RE DEALING.
WITH THE U. WITH A PERSON THAT
THE THE THE THE NOTION BEHIND
THE BOTTOM HAPPY TO WORK WITH
YOU SIR TERMS OF YOUR EXPERTISE
TO A LOT OF RESPECT FOR YOUR
BRAIN.
BUT BUT THE NOTION IS THAT
[inaudible]
THAT.
WE'RE TRYING TO DEAL WITH YOU
KNOW AGAIN WE DON'T STOP SPEECH
DAY WHAT YOU WANT.
JUST IDENTIFIED THAT EUROPE
MACHINE THAT'S ALL BUT IF I'M IN
MY VIDEO GAME IF IF I WALK UP TO
THE GUARD AND I HAVE TO HAVE A
SOMETHING FLOATING IN THE AIR
ABOVE HIM THAT SAYS.
YOU KNOW NOT A REAL PERSON
BECAUSE IN IN IN GAMES MODERN
GAMES LIKE WORLD WARCRAFT LEAGUE
OF LEGENDS.
IT'S NOT CLEAR WHEN YOU'RE
INTERACTING WITH.
AN ENTITY IN THE GAME WHETHER OR
NOT IT'S A REAL PERSON OR
SOMETHING THAT'S CONTROLLED BY
THE A I OF THE GAMEPLAY.
GIVEN THE POINT IS LIKE BUT I
GUESS THE QUESTION IS A CERTAIN
CHAIR IF I COULD.
WHAT I'M TRYING TO GET TO IS
THIS?
IF YOU'VE GOT SOME IDEAS TO MAKE
IT CLEAR I'M ALL FOR IT YOU KNOW
I DON'T KNOW MUCH ABOUT GAMES IN
MY THING IT WOULD LOVE TO GET
YOUR INSIGHTS ON THAT HAPPY TO
MAKE CHANGES IN THAT REGARD.
BUT WHAT I'M TRYING TO GET TO IS
TO MAKE SURE.
IN THESE CONTEXTS WHAT HAVE WE
SEEN WE DIDN'T KNOW WHAT TO EVEN
HIM EVEN THE MAJORITY LEADER
YOUNG GUY RIGHT.
THE GUY SIT NEXT TO HIM THESE
GUYS IN HAVE BOTS WHEN THEY WERE
KIDS DID YOU.
IT WAS A DIFFERENT WE HAD VIDEO
GAMES AND STUFF BUDGET THAT BOTS
TODAY IT'S ALL BECOME A REALLY
BIG THING.
AND SO I'M JUST TRYING TO GET TO
IT BY VIRTUE OF THE IMPACT IT'S
HAVING ON BUSINESS SONS IT'S
HAVING ON POLITICAL DISCOURSE.
AND TRYING TO BASICALLY LABEL IT
SO THAT BECAUSE THE YOUR
INTENTIONALLY TRYING TO DECEIVE
THAT'S THE POINT.
AND IT TALKS ABOUT INTENTIONAL
DECEPTION WE'RE AND FURIOUS
AGREEMENT OKAY WELL ALL WORK
WITH THE ON THIS AND AND AND
LET'S MENTAL TIME A BY A LUNCH
AND LET'S SEE IF WE CAN COME AYE
SOME FURTHER CLARIFIED.
BUT I MEAN IF MY POINT IS IF WE
RELY ON COMMON SENSE TO
INTERPRET THE LAW THEN A LOT OF
THE LEGAL SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA
WOULD BE MUCH BETTER.
WE HAVE TO GO ON IS IS WHAT IS
IN THE LAW AND THE WAY THAT
YOU'VE WRITTEN THIS MAKES IT
BROAD ENOUGH THAT.
A LOT OF DIFFERENT ASPECTS OF
HUMAN COMPUTER INTERACTION COULD
BE IMPACTED AND I JUST RAISE ONE
HAVE BEEN WE JUST OF VIDEO GAMES
BUT I'M WORRIED ABOUT --
VIRTUAL REALITY AND AUGMENT
FIELDS WHERE --
IS REALLY GOING TO BLUR THE
LINES BETWEEN --
INTERACTING WITH REAL PEOPLE
INTERACTING WITH MACHINE SO YOU
READ THE PREFACE WHEN VERY SURE
THAT WE THAT WE TIGHTEN DOWN.
OKAY YOU KNOW THE LOOK AT IT
WILL MEAN BY FIVE MISLEAD NO.
I JUST ALL I CAN TELL YOU IS IT
IS COMMON SENSE WHEN YOU READ
THE PREFACE TO OLIVER WENDELL
HOLMES THE COMMON LAW IN THE
FIRST PARAGRAPH IT SAYS THE LIFE
OF THE LAW.
HAS NOT BEEN LOGIC IT'S BEEN
EXPERIENCE EVERYTHING THAT WE DO
HERE EVERY LAW THAT WE WRITE
EVERY JUDGE'S INTERPRETATION IS
BASED ON EXPERIENCE.
IT IS ULTIMATELY REGULATION OF
THE HUMAN CONDITION AND SO THAT
IS IT IS ULTIMATELY COMMON SENSE
AND HAVE ALWAYS HAS TO BE EVERY
TIME WE WRITE A LAW.
THAT'S MY VIEW.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IF I COULD JUST
POINT OUT THERE IS A CARVE OUT
IN THE BILL THAT THIS ONLY
APPLIES TO CASES OF COMMERCIAL
SALE OF PRODUCTS OR TO INFLUENCE
THE VOTE IN AN ELECTION THAT
SOUNDS TO ME MORE LIKE AN
ENTERTAINMENT I SEE HOW YOU
COULD.
THAT COULD POTENTIALLY BE A
COMMERCIAL SALE --
WASN'T I I'M NOT FAMILIAR WITH
LANGUAGE ABOUT ELECTIONS I MEAN
COMMERCIAL MEANT THAT THIS IS
WHAT WE DO IS COMMERCIAL RIGHT
ON TOP TALK ABOUT A COMMERCIAL
PRODUCT.
ANYWAY UNTIL ONE WELL I DON'T I
DON'T HAVE LONG DEBATE YELLIN
FORWARD TO OUR DISCUSSION --
I'M GONNA HAVE TO OPPOSE THE
BILL TODAY BECAUSE ALL I HAVE TO
JUDGE IT ON IS WHAT'S IN PRINT
BUT I WOULD LOVE TO GET TO A
POSITION OF SUPPORT.
YEAH THAT WAS IT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND THAT WAS A FASCINATING
EXCHANGES OF THANK YOU VERY MUCH
A AND I DO INVITE ALL OF YOU TO
CONTINUE WORKING TOGETHER OUT
BECAUSE THIS IS AN AREA THAT WE
WANT TO SPEND A LITTLE MORE TIME
ON I THINK THIS IS.
BUT AS YOU SAY THAT --
MIST MISTER HERTZBERG IS VERY
IT'S GETTING LARITY OR OR
OTHERWISE SO I DO INVITE ALL OF
YOU TO GET ENGAGED --
LIVERMORE AND ON ARE THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS --
FOR THE SENATOR.
IT OPENS MISTER KALRA GUY.
I'M JUST GONNA SAY THAT THIS IS
A DIFFICULT AREA TO WADE INTO
BECAUSE YEAH.
I I DO AGREE THAT THERE ARE
CONCERNS OWES CONSTITUTIONAL
CONCERNS WHEN IT COMES TO
REGULATING SOMETHING LIKE THE
INTERNET FREEDOM SPEECH AND IT'S
OUR JOB TO BE WORRIED ABOUT IT'S
WE HAVE TO TAKE IT SERIOUSLY AND
I APPRECIATE.
THE COMMITTEE TAKING THE TIME TO
TAKE THAT SERIOUS AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR WILLINGNESS TO A
SEE THE BIGGER PICTURE MOVE THE
BALL MOVE THE BALL FORWARD
BECAUSE I COMPLETELY AGREE WITH
THAT NIGHT.
I MET MY BILLS ALL THE TIME TO
MOVE THE BALL FORWARD BECAUSE
IT'S A IT'S WHAT WE'RE SUPPOSED
TO DO HERE IS TO KEEP THE
CONVERSATION GOING BUT THIS IS
EXTREMELY.
BIG ISSUE WHEN IT COMES TO OUR
ONLINE OF WHAT PEOPLE ARE
EXPERIENCING I MEAN NOT JUST
WHAT YOU TALKED ABOUT THE
INCITING OF CERTAIN SPECIFIC
GROUPS.
PUSHING THEM INFORMATION TO GET
THEM TO BELIEVE SOMETHING THAT
ISN'T THE CASE AND WE ARE THERE
A LOT OF REAL WORLD APPLICATIONS
A LOT OF DAMAGE TO BE THAT IS
BEING DONE.
OBVIOUSLY TO POLITICAL AND CIVIL
DISCOURSE BUT THEN ALSO TO OUR
KIDS AND WHAT THEY'RE BEING
EXPERIENCE TO AN EXPOSED TO SO I
THINK THAT'S THE BROADER PICTURE
SO I THINK THAT YOU DID.
YOU'VE DONE THE RIGHT THING
TODAY ABOUT US AT THE SAME TIME
IT'S ALWAYS AND IT'S ALWAYS
EASIER TO NOWWAITING TO
CONVERSATION LIKE THIS BECAUSE
IT'S COMPLICATED AND CONVOLUTED
EVERYBODY'S GONNA BE UPSET.
BUT IT SO YOU GOT TO START
SOMEWHERE AND YOU GOT HAVE SOME
TYPES.
OF OF STARTING POINTS I THINK
THAT CRUCIATE THE OPPOSITION
CONTINUING TO TAKE TIME TO WORK
WITH SENATOR BECAUSE I KNOW HIM
TO BE A VERY.
HONORABLE AND REASONABLE PERSON
AND I I'M GONNA BE VOTING TODAY
AND I RESPECTFULLY MOVE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF MISTER
ABRAM LATER.
YEAH I JUST WANTED TO I THINK
THE SENATOR FIRST BILL I THINK
THIS IS YOU KNOW CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT ISSUE TO OUR DEMOCRACY
IS THE OTHER.
WITNESS POINTED OUT I THINK THIS
IS AN ADMIRABLE ATTEMPT --
TO TO IT TO THINK ABOUT IT TOM I
DID I DID WANT TO ECHO MY
COLLEAGUE'S COMMENTS I DO THINK
IT IS REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT WE
THINK ABOUT THE
CONSTITUTIONALITY OF THESE
ISSUES PARTICULARLY WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT GOVERNMENT
REGULATION OF POLITICAL SPEECH.
ACTUALLY DIFFER FROM MY FOR MY
COLLEAGUE OVER THERE I'M I'M
MORE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
REGULATION OF POLITICAL SPEECH
ON HIM ABOUT THE REGULATION A
COMMERCIAL SPEECH AND SO --
I APPRECIATE YOU STARTING THIS
CONVERSATION TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY BECAUSE I THINK IT SUPPORT
TO CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION BUT
I WOULD LIKE TO TALK WITH YOU A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT IN DETAIL TO
THINK ABOUT THIS BECAUSE AFTER
BY LUNCH.
TO ABSOLUTELY.
I I JUST I I'D INVITE IF NOTHING
[inaudible]
YEAH.
WE CAN WE CAN GO SOMEWHERE NICE --
BUT I THINK ANY TIME YOU DOESN'T
MAKE BAD THAT THE DISTRICT HER I
THINK ANY TIME THE GOVERNMENT IS
GOING TO WAIT UNTIL.
ON ANY TYPE OF REGULATION OF
POLITICAL SPEECH EVEN EVEN JUST
A LITTLE BIT I THINK WE NEED TO
PROCEED WITH CAUTION AND
PRECISION AND SO I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY OF A
CONVERSATION WITH YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH US SEE NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR I YEAH I
NEED A SECOND ON THAT I DO WANT
TO MAKE ONE CLARIFICATION AND
ARE THE AUTHORS WANT.
TO AMEND THE BILL --
TO REMOVE SECTION ONE SEVEN NINE
FOUR TWO AND THAT'S BOTH.
A AND B. AND ACTUALLY THERE'S A
SEA AS WELL SO JUST FOR THE
RECORD SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR TAKING THOSE AMENDMENTS.
TO SAY WITHOUT THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED AND SO TERRY PLEASE KALRA.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
ASSEMBLY ARTS ENTERTAINMENT
SPORTS TOURISM AND INTERNET
MEDIA COMMITTEE CHAO HIGH CHAU
AYE KILEY.
KILEY NOT VOTING THAT GO TO
LUNCH [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
BAKER.
THIS MESSAGE WITH THEM BAKER.
HOW BAKER NOT VOTING BERMAN I'VE
BERMAN AYE CALDERON?
CALDERON AYE GABRIEL BY REAL AYE
IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NO RARE FOOTAGE
[inaudible] FOR YOU HAVE FIVE
VOTES THAT WILL LEAD TO ROLL
OPEN I THINK THERE'S A COUPLE
MORE MISSING MEMBERS.
THANK YOU LIBERALLY THANK YOU.
FIVE FIVE ONE I DON'T. FIVE ONE
ZERO SARA DOT WAS OUR LAST BILLS
SO LET'S DO SOME ADMINISTRATIVE.
HOW LET ME LET ME ALSO ANNOUNCED
THAT US SENATE JACKSON HAS
DECIDED TO PULL HER BILL THAT
IT'S ITEM TO S. B.?
THREE FORTY SEVEN SO WITH THAT --
LET'S JUST THEM.
GO DOWN THE LIST AND PICK UP ALL
THE MISSING MEMBERS.
AND WHEN WE START WITH THE TOP.
STARTING WITH ITEM NUMBER ONE A
C. ARE A TO FIFTEEN KILEY.
UP PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
BERMAN.
I HAD A BERMAN AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN I AM MULLIN [inaudible]
WITH THE THAT'S A ZERO THE BILL
IS OUT [inaudible]
WE CLEAR.
THAT HE WAS A IT.
WAS A GOOD.
HI SO LET'S GO TO THE NEXT ITEM
AND THAT'S ITEM NUMBER THREE S.
B. NINE EIGHTY ONE THAT STOCK
BILL PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
KILEY.
DOT DOT.
KILEY AYE BAKER BAKER AYE BERMAN.
FOR AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MULLIN REYES
[inaudible]
THE BILL.
THAT BILL IS A ZERO LIKE IT'S
OUT THERE NEXT BILL IS SO ITEM
FOR WE JUST DID THE SENATOR
HERTZBERG BILL --
LET'S GO TO ITEM NUMBER FIVE SP
ELEVEN NINETY SIX JACKSON I MEAN
THAT'S A ON CONSENT.
SO CONSENT.
TO CONSENT AGAIN.
SO MCGUIRE CASO.
ITEM SEVEN THAT'S THERE HILL
BILL SP THIRTEEN FIFTY FIVE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
KILEY.
KILEY AYE BAKER.
BAKER AYE BERMAN AYE.
BERMAN AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN I MULLIN RAYOS. EIGHT ZERO
THAT BILL IS OUT TO FINALLY ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT SP THIRTEEN NINETY
SIX THAT'S GALGIANI PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
KILEY.
KILEY NO BAKER [inaudible]
GALGIANI.
BAKER AYE BERMAN AYE AYE BERMAN
AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MULLIN REYES. SIX TWO
TWO THAT BILL IS NOW.
SO WITH THAT I THINK THAT
CONCLUDES ALL THE INCLUDES A
RECALL [inaudible]
AND WHICH ONE HOW JUST FOR
CLARIFICATION --
SP TWELVE SEVENTY FOUR WAS PART
OF THE CONSENT SO THERE WERE TWO
ITEMS AS PART OF THE CONSENT
PACKAGE AND THAT IS SP.
TWELVE SEVENTY FOUR AND S. B.
ELEVEN NINETY SIX JACKSON.
SO WILL I LEAVE THEIR OPEN FOR
THE NEXT FEW MINUTES AFTER THE
NEXT A MEMBER.
YOU YEAH YEAH SO GREAT.
SO BAKER AYE ON CONSENT THINKING
[inaudible]
WE CAN [inaudible]
NATALIE.
I THINK HE HAS [inaudible]
WE'RE BETTER.
LET ME JUST ANALYSIS.
IT'S GOOD TO CONSENT TARA.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ON THE CONSENT AGENDA PLEASE.
BERMAN AYE AYE BERMAN AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MULLIN RADIUS.
THE CONSENT IS OUT.
THAT WOULD BE ELEVEN NINETY SIX
AND TWELVE SEVENTY FOR SO.
WILL LEAD THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE
TWO MISSING MEMBERS ARE RUNNING
A LITTLE LATE PRESENTING BILLS.
JUST FINISHING UP OKAY
[inaudible]
OKAY.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU.
I NEED TO BE REMINDED SERVICES
WILL HAVE.
TO FIGURE OUT HOW LIKE DO YOU.
LIKE THIS IDEA [inaudible]
YEAH.
I GUESS WAS IT OKAY YEAH BECAUSE
YOU DO IT.
SO NOW IT'S WORKABLE OKAY NEVER
OKAY NOW
.
SO AT THIS TIME I'D LIKE TO LIVE
THE CALL ON HIS SPEED ONE
THOUSAND ONE HERTZBERG PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS MULLIN.
AYE AYE MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE
REYES.
FEDERAL IS OUT.